big news overnight donald trump's
personal lawyer 76 year old rudy
giuliani has tested
positive for coronavirus donald trump
confirming the diagnosis via twitter
yesterday saying
quote rudy giuliani by far the greatest
mayor in the history of new york city
and who has been working tirelessly
exposing the most corrupt election by
far
in the history of the united states has
tested positive for the china virus back
to calling it the china virus
get better soon rudy we will carry on
now of course
there is nothing surprising about this
rudy giuliani has been flying daily
all over the country for weeks sitting
in rooms with 100 or more different
people
every day many without masks all to
promote
bogus voter fraud conspiracies the only
surprising thing
about rudy and coronavirus is it took
this long for rudy to test positive so
there's a few elements to this story
first is the personal health element
rudy's 76
at minimum he's overweight i don't know
if he would be considered obese
unsure about other comorbidities so
question one is
how serious of a case will rudy have and
as with everybody i hope he gets uh
to experience a full and speedy recovery
many people do not
that's question one part two how many
people did rudy giuliani expose or give
the virus to in the days prior to the
positive test
he was all over different hearings
without a mask around lawmakers from
different states
also not wearing masks next to another
trump attorney jenna ellis
also without a mask so he may be another
super spreader
arizona's legislature has shut down
because they were all exposed by rudy
giuliani just a few days ago that's part
number two
part number three how does this impact
trump's continued voter fraud campaign
will they
keep having hearings and filing bogus
legal complaints with other attorneys
working for them
will rudy work from home who knows rudy
as of last night uh had been checked
into a hospital for treatment
and then fourth and this is just amazing
the number of people convinced that this
is actually part of the conspiracy is
stunning
i jokingly tweeted yesterday and anyone
who knows me knows it's obvious satire i
posted to twitter
a fake conspiratorial post again
obviously joking i said quote doesn't
anybody find it a little suspicious
that just as rudy was traveling all over
the country ready to expose affidavits
that would overturn the election
he gets coveted and now has to stop
exposing the fraud
it's too convenient now that was a joke
and
somehow this tweet got caught in some
kind of twitter trending topics thing
and people were agreeing with me people
responded yeah it is a bit of a stretch
a woman named marlene responded yep and
i don't believe trump had it either
a woman named debbie suggested rudy
doesn't really have kovid
but that quote i wonder if trump
sidelined him
because of all the losing it got so bad
that i had to post a follow-up tweet
where i said holy you know what
i can't believe i have to add this
but my post is satire you lunatics
so that's very very bad and of course we
wish rudy the best and a full recovery
and at the same time we hope that he
will drop the bogus voter fraud nonsense
because it's been
so so corrosive to democracy
rudy giuliani positive for coronavirus
and
in the hospital and we now must
discuss um georgia
georgia which will determine who ends up
controlling the senate beyond january
20th let's go to that next
this episode is sponsored by blue chew
one of the things i make a priority on
the show
is not to perpetuate stigma for things
that don't deserve it we've talked about
mental health we've talked about many
things where we should all just be
respectful adults period and we would be
better off
and blue chew can increase performance
and give you that extra confidence you
may be looking for bluetooth.com
blue like the color blue is the first
chewable with the same fda approved
ingredient
as in viagra and cialis it can be taken
day or night even on a full stomach
since it's chewable
blue chew is prescribed online by
licensed
doctors you don't have to go to a
doctor's office you don't have to wait
in line at a pharmacy it ships right to
your door
in a discrete package they're made in
the usa and since blue chew prepares and
ships direct
it's cheaper than a pharmacy and best of
all
no more awkwardness we've got a special
deal for our viewers and listeners go to
bluetooth.com
get your first shipment free when you
use our promo code pacman that's
p-a-k-m-a-n
pages five dollars shipping that's bluee
chew.com promo code pacman to try it
totally free blue chew
is the better cheaper faster choice
and we thank them for sponsoring the
david pakman show